Why don't we try? Let's go to is it
Yone from Norway. Yone from Norway.
Yes, sir. Yes, sir. How are you?
I'm good, thank you. All right. You good safe?
Yeah. Yeah. Are you in Oslo or where are you?
Well, I'm about one and a half hours
drive away from Oslo, so. OK, yeah.
How much how many hours of sunlight
a day do you get right now?
Hmm, well, during covid, if I like,
look out the window, I get some, but
no, no, no, I mean, not not you personally.
I know where you are. Yeah, I know we have.
I was just joking. We have like six to
seven hours, I think. OK, all right.
Yeah, no, I was just wondering, like, because
looking looking at the situation from Norway,
like how how do you think you can, like, fix
like reclaim your integrity? Do you think it's
enough to do you think it's enough, like trying
to put the Trump in this place? Because I can
see it like even if you don't manage to impeach
him or like giving giving him some some larger
repercussions. Yeah, just trying that will send
a really good signal like. It's a good signal,
just trying to impeach him, right?
But it is if he's not convicted,
you're saying, listen, I think the rehabilitation
of the United States is partially going to happen
from just having Joe Biden in the return of actual
diplomatic taking diplomacy seriously. I really do
think that many countries are eager to get back
to a normal relationship with the U.S. So I think
just having Joe Biden back and a proper diplomatic
corps and ambassadors, I think that will be a big
piece of it. But I don't think that will be
enough. I think the U.S. is going to have to
become a leader on coronavirus and to to regain
some of the respect that we lost under Donald
Trump. I think the United States is going to have
to figure out, you know, Trump bailed on the Iran
deal for no reason. Iran didn't break any of the
rules during the deal. The U.S. is going to have
to figure out how to regain credibility there.
So I think that it will partially happen under
Biden just because Biden will be normal. But I
think that there is still work to do. I don't
think it will ultimately be about whether
the Senate convicts Trump on impeachment.
No, no, no. But just sending the
signal and trying. Yeah, I agree.
My pleasure. John from Norway. All right.
Make sure you're getting that vitamin D
there. Thanks to everybody who called.
I am out of time for today,
but I will take calls again in the future.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.